willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung in der
wir uns mit augustinus befassen werden
augustinus war ein spätantike philosoph
christlich geprägt und hat sich sehr
prominent mit dem guten und bösen
befasst vor allem dieser bekannt für die
auseinandersetzung mit dem bösen aber
unser seminar gilt er in guten und bösen
wir müssen also immer wieder schauen wie
verhält sich die theorie des bösen bei
augustinus auch zum guten ja das ist so
eine darstellung eine
antike darstellung vielleicht spätantike
von augustinus und er hat ein buch
geschrieben das heißt über das freie
willens vermögen lateinischer titel die
liebe trio sie kennen sicherlich alle
das wort er vielleicht schon mal gehört
er heißt einfach nur
willkürlich also im atrium das ist das
was wir im deutschen mit dem wort
willkür bezeichnet willkür ist natürlich
ein wortes ist auch sehr ambivalent
willkürlich bedeutet häufig auch so was
wie grundlos ja willkürlich das hat auch
gar kein grund
augustinus meint hier mit der willkür
nichts grundloses sondern etwas was
unsere individuelle freiheit betrifft
also bild ist unsere
entscheidungsinstanz unserer
entscheidung vermögen und 20
individuelles entscheidungs vermögen zum
guten oder zum bösen mir sehen also er
behandelt das böse jetzt nicht mehr so
sehr und logisch oder kosmologische oder
metaphysisch wie wir es bei pro team
gesehen hatten der von den sein spricht
der von der natur der dinge spricht die
böse ist es geht ihnen hier ihr um das
individuum um das subjekt rund um die
prozesse waren die willentlichen
prozesse die in diesem subjekt
stattfinden und die dann am ende zu dem
für was man kann ja wir haben paar
leitfaden worin liegt nach augustinus
der grund des bösen das ist natürlich
auch ein thema was sie behandeln können
und wie verhält sich der begriff des
bösen bei augustinus zudem bei kloten
ergänzen könnten fragen wie sich das
gute dann zum bösen verhält man kann
natürlich auch immer wenn man die
theorie des bösen behandelt weil die
ausführung über das böse immer im
umkehrschluss fragen was folgt daraus
für das gute
ja da gibt sie ein sehr langes zitat das
möchte ich auch nicht ganz vorlesen ich
hatte es in der letzten sitzung schon
vorgelesen dass es aus seinen
bekenntnissen aus den konfessionen ist
und dieses selbst erkenntnisse diese
bekenntnisse geben ganz individuelle
auskunft über sein leben sehr zu
empfehlen das ist ein sehr langer text
aber wirklich weltliteratur falls sie
mal die gelegenheit haben diesen sie mal
rein das ist wirklich auch noch sehr
modern weil hier einfach die
subjektivität die individualität ganz
ins zentrum rückt das ist durchaus sehr
modern was augustinus gemacht es gibt
dann auch noch nachfolgende philosophen
wie zb russo vielleicht gehört die
konfession auch die bekenntnisse wo sie
in augustin ischer man ihr auch sein
innenleben dem leser und die leserin
offenlegt hat es ist hat also wirklich
tradition und das ist ganz bedeutend und
er berichtet jetzt augustinus von seiner
jugend wo er
willentlich das böse getan hatte
und zwar sagt er er sei willens gewesen
einen diebstahl zu begehen
und mpg diesen diebstahl
nicht durch die not und nicht durch den
mangel also hier mangel könnte hier
wieder denken
ist das böse eine beraubung ein mangel
an sein also hier sagte das hat nichts
mit mangels tun sondern durch den ekel
vor der gerechtigkeit und der gier nach
ungerechtigkeit kälter es ist auch
ziemlich modernes phänomen
vielleicht haben sie schon mal von sata
das buchdeckel
gelesen falls nicht mache ich dann oben
rechts in der youtube aufzeichnet einen
link zu einem seminar von mir herein
hinein wo es um die existenz geht und
zum thema existent hat eben sagt dieses
buch der ekel geschrieben und ich finde
es ganz modernen also hier kann man
schöne bezüge herstellen also es ging um
den ekel
gute das böse als ekel am guten
und der dir nach ungerechtigkeit er
stahl dasjenige was er im überfluss
besaß hätte es eigentlich gar nicht
stellen müssen weil er hatte kein
begehrte keine begierde danach und nicht
der genuss also nicht unser interesse an
der sache war der grund der diebstahl
sondern
der grund des diebstahls war der
diebstahl selbst
oder genau genommen die sünde die
augustinus begehrte also hat das böse
tatsächlich um das bösen getan hier
unten schreibt der boshaft war ich nur
um boshaft zu sein das ist eine ganz
spannende frage in der philosophie
können wir böse sein oder sind wir böse
tun wir dies ist nur um des bösen willen
und viele würden sagen nein selbst
markante ein aufgeklärter philosoph
einfluss auf die aufklärung
der sagt wir können gar nicht das böse
um das bösen tool weil dann werden wir
ein teuflisches wesen das ist ganz
spannend augustinus ist ja noch viel
christlich theologische als kant und
trotzdem vertreter diese sehr starke
these also nach immanuel kant wäre das
was augustinus da tut eigentlich boshaft
ein boshaftes böse ein teuflisches böse
denn das boshafte das böse nur um des
bösen willen zu tun ja
also hier ganz spannender text
und ja das ist ein bekenntnis also was
ist jetzt der grund das augustinus das
böse tut wir haben gesehen ist das böse
als solches wir aber warum
reizt uns das böse ja man könnte sich
überlegen dass hier
augustinus durch diese gebote die eben
auch unter anderem das stillen verbieten
die zehn gebote dass er dadurch
provoziert wurde also wenn man ein
gesetz bekommt ein gebot vernimmt das
gebot des guten dann kann es sein dass
ich in uns etwas dagegen empört man
könnte auch sagen dieser ekel ist eine
art von empörung
und warum empört sich da etwas in uns ja
weil wir durch dieses gebot uns in
manchen situation eingeschränkt sehen
wir sehen uns vielleicht sogar
gedemütigt
angesichts der gerechtigkeit es schränkt
irgendwie unsere freiheit ein meinen wir
zumindest man könnte jetzt ja auch
argumentieren dass gute oder die gebote
vergrößern doch gerade unsere freiheit
weil sie uns auch die richtige spur
bringen aber es gibt eben auch die
andere auf ansicht dass da unsere
individuellen interessen die uns gerade
bewegen dass die da von einer instanz
verboten werden und zwar kategorisch
jetzt kennen dieses problem dann auch
später bei paulus dieser christlichen
tradition dass paulus sagt also ich
kenne es schon davor bei paulus genau
genommen dass paulus sagt dass diese
gebote
uns anstößig waren ja die sünden nahmen
anstoß am geburtstag paulus und ja das
ist also ganz ganz spannende frage wie
sich das
verhältnis zur freiheit
möchte ich jetzt nur eben als text zu
bedenken geben
und dann sagt augustinus weiter und der
sich ganz zentrale unterscheidung wir
pflegen auf zweifache weise von übel und
übel heißt eben mal um auf
lateinisch auf griechisch ist es dass
cacau
über zu sprechen zum einen zeigen dir
jemand habe etwas böses getan zum
anderen etwas schlechtes sei erlitten
worden das ist ganz wichtig weil hier
findet sich die unterscheidung zwischen
dem mal um physik um das physische böse
das physische übel muss man genau
genommen sagen wie zum beispiel ein leid
was ein zustößt oder eine krankheit das
ist dieses natürliche schlechte und dann
gibt eben noch das moralische schlechte
und das ist eigentlich strengen sind das
was wir lösen früher oder vielleicht
auch noch heute nannte man auch äußere
umstände die
uns irgendwie betrafen seines
naturkatastrophen oder
krankheiten böse aber heute neigt man
doch immer mehr dazu sagen sie sind
nicht wirklich böse weil das böse setzt
voraus dass da eine böse absicht
zugrunde lag
aber dass die ganz zentral
unterscheidung also das natürliche möbel
und das moralische böse als das mal um
was in lateinischen breites bezeichnen
kann einfach nur das schlechteste ist
das moralisch schlecht was körperliche
vielleicht das wird jetzt hier
weiter unterschieden in ein moralisches
dass meine moral und das malen physikum
ja noch ein weiteres zitat wenn die
sünden von denjenigen sehen her stammen
die gott geschaffen hat dieses sehen
aber frankfurt stammen wieso sind dann
die sünden nicht indirekt auf gott
zurück das ist letztendlich wieder die
tbc frage die wir auch dann in der
nächsten sitzung kennenlernen werden wo
es um leibnitz geht
wenn gott allmächtig all gültig und
allwissend ist so wird gott meistens
tage stellt wie kann es dann sein dass
er zulässt dass wir böses tun er könnte
es doch verhindern sind da nicht doch
unsere bösen taten indirekt nicht direkt
aber indirekt eben durch uns vermittelt
auf gott zurückzuführen das wäre
natürlich eine ansicht die
augustinus als christlicher denker nicht
vertreten könnte gibt es so fragte
weiter also einen anderen urheber des
jähnigen übels das wie wir nun wissen
nicht von gott verursacht wird hier
liegt es nahe und augustinus war zeit
seines lebens teilweise manchen phasen
eben auch dieser position zu geneigt
einem anarchistischen position zu
vertreten das bedeutet die manege ist
ische position sagt dass es eine gute
und eine böse macht gibt die die welt
bestimmt das ist eine kosmologische
theorie also die der ganze kosmos die
ganze welt ist bestimmt durch zwei
prinzipien das gute prinzip und das böse
prinzip und diese zwei prinzipien
befinden sich in widerstreit und durch
die ganze geschichte weg zieht sich
dieser kampf zwischen gut und böse das
natürlich ein sehr dramatisches bild
das ein dualismus also hier findet man
zwei prinzipien und wir sind mehr oder
weniger spielball dieser zwei mächte
seine auffassung kann natürlich
augustinus aus christlicher sicht auch
nicht vertreten warum weil nach dieser
auffassung gott eben nicht allmächtig
hätte er dann einen bösen gegenspieler
der von ihm nicht besiegt werden könnte
also das ist eine position die
augustinus teilweise vertreten hatte
aber er hat sich dann davon abgewendet
von dieser mann ist zwischen position
nun gut da du mich zwingt das ist immer
der die euro partner mit dem ihr
augustinus in dieser schrift die bab
trio kommuniziert nun gut sagte dadurch
zwingend einzugestehen dass wir das böse
du nicht lernen dann sag mal wie es
kommt dass wir böses tun das ist diese
lateinische bindung und male verkehr
muss also woher
vielleicht auch warum
handeln wackere heißt handeln wir
schlecht
ja wie kommt es dass wir lösen handelt
das die entscheidende frage das sind
also die frage nach den gründen des
bösen das möchte jetzt hier augustinus
analysieren denkt die gründe des bösen
können nicht in gottlieben das wäre es
gegen seine gültigkeit an güte und sie
können auch nicht einen bösen gegen
prinzip gegen das wenig liebe gottes an
mächtigkeit das heißt es muss irgendwie
in uns liegen wenn die sünden von
denjenigen seelen herrscht am die gott
geschaffen hat diese zählen auch von
gott stammen dass es ihnen immer noch
die frage warum sind sie dann nicht auf
ihn zurückzuführen das hatten wir
behandelt und jetzt sagt er weiter es
ist klar dass nichts anderes als die
lust in jede hand bösen taten herrscht
ok und jetzt analysierte das weiter ein
leben ohne furcht begehren nämlich nicht
nur alle guten zahlen auch alle bösen
der unterschied liegt aber darin dass
die guten danach streben in dem sie die
liebe
abwenden
von ihnen dingen die man nicht besitzen
kann ohne gefahr sie wieder zu verlieren
die bösen aber versuchen alle
hindernisse zu beseitigen und diese
dinge in sicherheit genießen zu können
und deshalb führen sie ein
verbrecherisches und schändliches leben
also es geht letztendlich in gut und
böse darum wie wir uns zu den dingen zu
den gütern die wir erstreben
verhalten
und die guten da haben wir den begriff
es drohten die wendet sich eben ab von
den dingen die
vergänglich sind
weil wir sie nicht in der hand haben ja
sie können sich überlegen was das ist
das sind natürlich dinge genussmittel
genuss dinge vergängliche dinge und die
guten wenden sich zu den ewigen dingen
die man nicht verlieren kann die bösen
aber wollen diese vergänglichen dinge
genießen und weil sich diese bedingt
diese dinge nicht beständig erhalten
lassen
sehen sie sich in einer situation
ständig nach anderen endlichen dingen zu
streben um eben ihre befriedigung zu
erhalten das heißt es ist ein sehr
unstetes leben man muss hier tricks
anwenden um diese güter wieder zu
erwerben man hat einfach eine innere
unruhe so beschreibt sie augustinus das
böse und das gute wäre dementsprechend
eine haltung der ruhe einhaltung der
stabilität man sieht ja so ein bisschen
wie der plattform oder pro team im
hintergrund sie erinnern sich an die
idee des guten idee des guten ist
dasjenige was
absolut existiert was dauerhaft
existiert das keinen wandel unterworfen
ist während eben nach platon und auch
pro team diese vergänglichen dinge ihr
diese schatten dinge bezeichnet ja die
eben nach platon und lud ihn ein mangel
an zahlen aufweisen um die von blasen
floating tendenziell böse genannt werden
hier geht's jetzt augustinus nicht daran
dass er sagt diese vergänglichen dinge
sind böse sondern der grund des bösen
bestätigt uns im streben nach diesen
vergänglichen
aber die dinge als solche die
vergänglichen dinge sind nicht selbst
wenn sie nur unser verhältnis zu diesen
dingen bewirkt das böse herr
ja noch ein weiteres zitat was dem
herrschenden und der tugend mächtigen
geist gleich oder übergeordnet ist macht
ihm der begierde nicht dienstbar wegen
der gerechtigkeit was aber niedriger ist
vermag dies nicht wegen der schwäche wie
unsere feststellungen zeigen bleibt also
nur dass nichts anderes den geist zum
genossen der begierde macht als der
eigene wille und die freie entscheidung
das ganz zentrale der grund dass wir
eben etwas begehren liegt nicht in den
dingen selbst die uns irgendwie zwingen
von außen sondern dass wir uns zu diesen
dingen verhalten sei es die höheren
dinge die stabil sind die man beständig
sind oder seines die niedrigeren bringe
die vergehen die uns täuschen die schein
haft sind es ist immer unser wille und
unsere freie entscheidung die dafür
sorgen dass wir dem ein oder anderen
folgen
das ist ziemlich zentral und das ist
jetzt durchaus eine wandlung in der
theorie des bösen buben vergleich zu
bluten weiter sagte er zu sagen
dialogpartner du siehst also schon wie
ich meine dass es an unserem willen
liegt ob wir dieses so groß und waren
gut genießen oder beeren denn was liegt
so sehr an willen wie der wille selbst
jeder der einen guten willen hat hat
sicher das wenige was allen irdischen
reichen und den listen des körpers bei
weitem vorzuziehen ist weil wir nicht
hatte für jeden der tat etwas das besser
ist als die güter über die wir keine
macht haben und dass ihm allein der
wille
sich selbst geben könnte hier wird noch
mit der wille ganzen zentrum gesteht
gestellt der wille sagt er der ist der
ist grund seiner selbst hier sagt dass
den was liegt so sehr an filme wie der
video selbst der wille ist letztendlich
sein eigener grund das ist eine recht
moderne form von willensfreiheit harry
frankfurt ein moderner philosoph da mach
ich dann auch oben rechts und links rein
da hatte ich auch schon mal ein seminar
angeboten der sagt unser freier wähler
ist dann frei wenn er sich zu sich
selbst verhalten kann also wenn der
wille sich selbst reflektiert und
genauso könnte man auch diesen satz hier
verstehen was liegt so sehr in vehlen
wie der wille selbst der wille ist
selbst sein eigener grund der wille
verhält sich zu seinen wünschen oder wir
verhalten uns willentlich zu unserem
willen letztendlich wir fragen uns
wollen wir das wirklich wenn wir
vernünftig sind können wir das wirklich
wollen wir finden uns verschiedene
wünsche vor anders willens regungen aber
können wir das möglich wollen wir müssen
uns immer wieder zu unserem video
verhalten
ja es geht also darum dass wir in
unserem verhältnis zum willen das wollen
was eben
zuständig ist
und nicht dasjenige worüber wir keine
macht haben nicht dasjenige was
vergänglich was uns täuscht und was uns
auch immer wieder am ende bestätigt
seien jetzt hier sagte schon in einigen
uns darauf dass die menschen ist durch
den willen verdienen durch den willen
aber auch das unglückliche leben und
dass sie es so verdienen dass sie es
auch erhalten und entsteht aber ein
eigenartiger widerspruch und wenn wir
ihn nicht sorgfältig untersuchen könnte
er unsere bisherige sorgfältig erwogen
und gesicherte beweisführung
zuhören denn wie kann jemand will
endlich ein unglückliches leben erleiden
wenn schlechterdings niemand unglücklich
geben will das ist die spannende frage
warum tun wir überhaupt das böse wenn
doch das böse am ende zu einem
unglücklichen leben führt
damals noch erinnern hier an diese
bekenntnisse von augustinus davor er
sagte
ja man kann das böse auch um das bösen
willen tun das ist eine möglichkeit wenn
es das gute provoziert das wäre so eine
möglichkeit eine andere möglichkeit wäre
sagen wir tauschen uns wie wir denken
dass das was eigentlich schlecht ist das
gute sei und wollen eigentlich immer das
gute aber unterliegen in der einer
selbsttäuschung und tun dann eben im
grund eben doch das böse wir glauben
dass wir den guten nach streben aber es
ist im grunde genommen nur das gute für
uns uns als individuen aber aufs ganze
gesehen wie es eben nicht das gute und
diese phänomene kennen sie die sieht man
täglich in allen medien liest man dass
menschen sich zu viel vornehmen dass es
sich dann am ende
übernehmen und am ende betrügerisch
werden und in einer art von eigenen
gefängnis leben indem sie sich immer
wieder belügen anschein gebäude sie
verstricken sich immer weiter sie
versuchen immer weiter nach ausreden und
ja sind am ende selbst gefangen diesem
konstrukt von begierden und lügen die
sie selbst aber für das gute halten
als ich ist eine ganz wichtige fragen
aufgeworfen die selben dinge gebraucht
also der eine schlecht und der andere
gut und jener der sie schlecht gebraucht
hängt ihnen im liebe an und verwickelt
sich in sie das ist diese verwicklung
was ich vorhin diese verstrickung auch
genannt hat dass man da gar nicht mehr
rauskommt als er verwickelt sich die
dinge die eher schlecht gebraucht er das
ja dass die ist nämlich diesem ding
unterworfen die doch ihm unterworfen
sein sollte und er macht sie für sich zu
bieten während doch er selbst dass sie
ein gutes sein sollte indem ihr sie
ordnet und gut verwendet wer sich aber
wer sie aber gerecht gebraucht zeigt
zwar dass sie güter sind haben nicht
sind sie machen ihn nicht gut oder
besser sollen sie werden es ihr durch
ihn
dann klebt auch nicht in der liebe dann
klebt er auch nicht in liebe an ihnen
und macht sie nicht gleichsam zu
gliedern seiner seele wie es durch die
liebe geschieht damit sie ihnen nicht
durchfall und volles einstellen wenn sie
abgeschnitten werden vielmehr erhebt er
sich völlig über sie bereits unnötigen
fouls zu besitzen und zu verwalten und
noch mehr bereit sie aufzugeben und
nichts besitzen da das also ist meinst
du silber und gold seien anzuklagen
wegen der geizigen oder das essen wegen
der gefräßigen oder der wein wegen der
surfer oder
die weiblichen gestalt wegen der hörer
und ehebrecher usw vor allem da du doch
sie ist dass der hat das feuer gut
gebrauchte gift mich hat das brot aber
verbrecherisch als hier sieht man wieder
an etwas
antiquiertes bild auch der frau die
natürlich auch in dieser tradition
häufig
eben als
versuchung dargestellt wurde ist
natürlich ein riesentopf aus der sich
durch die ganze geistesgeschichte zieht
entscheidend ist doch aber jetzt hier
für das argument dass wir selbst uns
nicht von den gütern abhängig machen
soll dass wir uns nicht in sie
verwickeln soll dass wir diesen dingen
nicht unterworfen sein soll sondern
diese dinge diese güte was auch immer
sie sind die sollen uns unterworfen
zeiten das ist letztendlich die frage
nach der autonomie als sie ist das
moderne stichwort autobahn machen wir
uns abhängig von den äußeren dingen von
dem nicht beständigen dingen die wir
nicht in der hand haben dann sind wir
anfällig dafür dass sich die dinge
ändern wir sind spielbälle von äußeren
umständen
oder
ordnen sie wir werden wir die dinge uns
unter als heben wir uns über diese dinge
und
verhaltens dabei autonom selbstbestimmt
lassen wir uns fremd bestimmen von
äußeren umständen oder bestimmen wir die
äußeren umstände selbst versuchen wir
selbst die initiative zu mehr also hier
steht im hintergrund des verständnisses
autonomie oder hätte also wer böse
handelt nach augustinus der verhält sich
auch hetero- nom er macht sich abhängig
und wird darin auch irgendwie uns frei
er wird aus freiheit gewissermaßen und
frei ergibt er dass sie gibt seine
freiheit auf um dadurch von diesen
dingen abhängig zu sein und es sehen sie
in allen möglichen konstellationen der
sehen sie der gesamten literatur das
sehen sie wenn sie die zeitung
aufschlagen
die menschen neigen immer wieder dazu
sich abhängig zu machen sei es von geld
sei es von irgendwelchen werten sei es
von berühmtheit bekanntheit von dingen
die sie im grunde nicht in der hand und
wenn sie das machen dann merken diese
menschen merken wir alle dass wir
versuchen müssen diese vergänglichkeit
der dinge entgegen zettel wir müssen
dann also uns anstrengen aus diesen
endlichen guten etwas beständiges zu
machen und merken nicht dass wir
eigentlich uns von diesen dingen
abwenden zu indem wir aber bei diesen
dingen bleiben diesen endlichen die uns
auch immer wieder täuschen und uns
entkleiden gerade darin im versuch das
endliche beständig zu machen gerade
darin werde böse weil wir gewissermaßen
den hals nicht voll genug bekommen und
uns wieder neue strategien überlegen
müssen neue güter zu besitzen wenn die
alte nennt
vielleicht sind und dann passiert es
leicht dass wir dann betrügen dass wir
lügen dass wir in geldnot geraten und so
weiter und so fort das ist immer diese
alte strategie die die menschheit nach
wie vor immer noch wieder macht also sie
scheint eben nichts gelernt zu haben
hier sind davor nicht gefeit uns diesen
endlichen gütern zu unterwerfen sagt
augustinus und ich denke das trifft
ja dann sagt er weiter es ist völlig
klar dass nicht die dinge selbst zu
beschuldigen sind sondern die menschen
die sich schlecht gebrauchen also es
gibt die auffassung dass bestimmte dinge
böse sind
das war durchaus üblich in der damaligen
tradition dass man sagt irgendwie das
endliche ist schlecht oder sie kann sich
an putin dann mache ich oben rechts auch
den linken das platin sagt die materie
ist böse und schlecht
hiergegen wendet sich augustin as
augustinus sagt es sind nicht die dinge
die schlecht sind auch wenn sie endlich
sind auch wenn sie und täuschen können
sondern es ist immer unser wieder selbst
es sind wir selbst die dadurch indem wir
uns zu diesen dingen verhalten einen
bösen willen entwickeln und böse handeln
weil wir uns dadurch und frei machen
weiter sagte es ist völlig klar es steht
aber fest sagte weiter das ist am willen
blickt war es jeder als zu jagen dessert
jagen das meint wonach er das sie strebt
und zu empfangen des wählt und dass der
geist durch nichts aus der burg seine
herrschaft und aus der rechten ordnung
heraus geworfen wird als nur durch den
willen es ist auch klar dass nicht
irgendeine sache zu beschuldigen ist
wenn jemand sich schlecht gebraucht sagt
derjenige selbst der sie vielleicht
gebraucht das ist manchmal eine
wiederholung davon es geht um den
gebrauch es geht um unseren umgang mit
den dingen
der die dinge etwas gute oder schlechte
macht und zwar eben vor allem dann wenn
es sich um ähnliche dinge handelt wenn
es sich jetzt um höhere dinge beständige
dinge ewige dinge dann scheint es so zu
sein dass unser bloßer bezug zu diesen
dingen schon das gute bewirkt die frage
stellt sich ob wir auch die ewigen dinge
im moralischen sinne gebrauchen können
das ist eine spannende frage die
augustinus ziemlich thematisiert er
spricht jetzt hier vor allem um die
endlichen vergänglichen dinge und hier
geht es eben darum dass wir uns ihn
autonom gegenüber verhalten und ihn
nicht unterliegen aber es hängt immer
von unseren willen selbst hat ob diese
dinge dann am ende für uns oder schlecht
sind ja das ist jetzt die auszeichnung
gewesen und wir gehen dann über
zum nächsten thematik das ist dann
thomas von aquin
übersichtliches handeln was er in seiner
summer theologie in der summe seiner
theologisch philosophischen
untersuchungen dargestellt hat